Too Fast Too Furious surprisingly isn't
the second part of this franchise
instead that honor goes to the
turbocharged prelude for 2 Fast 2
Furious a short film which sees Brian on
the run after letting Dom Go free for
some reason this leads to a nationwide
manhunt with his face plastered all over
the Nightly News that sort of thing
tends to present a problem when you're
driving across America winning street
races like some sort of gear shaft
version of Johnny Appleseed when cops
sees his vehicle while Brian's driving
through Texas he's able to hitch a ride
with an unnamed woman who recognizes his
face possibly because of his uncanny
resemblance to Lance Harbor from Varsity
Blues after that he buys a new car wins
more street races and finds himself in
Miami the city where the heat is on to
see the full video and more great
content check out our Channel And
subscribe